para ti de santiago guillermo lasso se
enfrenta con un país profundamente
endeudado no enfrenta a este momento
tres crisis la crisis y la pandemia la
crisis económica que deberá enfrentar
este nuevo mandatario activo que pasará
diez años y pasar quince años de
gobiernos de socialismo del siglo 21
para hacerse con la presidencia del país
andino es usted hacer intento como
recibe guillermo lasso del país bueno
recibe con muchos retos ha dicho que
tendrá que manejar la vacunación una de
las principales crisis en este país ha
dicho que ya se conoce por parte de la
nueva ministra de salud a partir del 30
de mayo se reactivará la vacunación en
este país y en este sentido guillermo
lasso ha hecho énfasis que
ratificarán su propuesta de gobierno de
vacunar a 9 millones de personas en sus
100 primeros días de gobierno y lograr
inclusive con la organización y la
estructura del consejo nacional de
electoral los siete días de la semana de
igual forma ha llamado a la unidad
nacional ha dicho también unas frases
durante en su discurso se ha acabado la
persecución política en el país a pesar
que no se expresó específicamente en
contra de rafael correa- dicho que no
perseguirá a nadie pero tampoco dará
paso a las comisiones especiales para
revisar los fallos judiciales que los
relacionan han sido algunas de las
frases significativas en algunos minutos
ya saldrá el nuevo presidente de ecuador
guillermo lazo de la asamblea nación